you that we are at least live on youtube
and we are live
on clubhouse uh this is an experiment
as i say most experiments fail uh but if
you never make the experiment you never
know how bad of a failure you are i
don't know
i'm talking today with with a phenomenal
a hero of mine
uh someone that i've admired for a very
long time i did an experiment
i reached out to him on linkedin and and
he said yes so this is great this is
wonderful to
welcome to the into the impossible
podcast none other than dr scott
parazynski
how are you today scott great to be with
you ryan i'm thrilled to be part of this
uh
podcast with with you and and uh yeah i
i've
been very uh admiring of the work that
you've done and all the stuff you did in
antarctica in particular that's an area
where we overlap so
i want to hear some stories from you too
absolutely you know i was uh
before i got to the last chapter of the
sky below
i was like awesome i've been to
somewhere this guy has not been
this guy is a literal cosmic voyager
but i've been to the south pole and in
chapter 25 you're like
one place i haven't been is the south is
antarctica
and i'm like yeah i'm gonna be do
something go boldly where scott has not
gone before and then chapter 26 i'm not
gonna spoil it
scott ends up there and he finds a very
expensive rock well i'm not gonna talk
too much about that
but uh i love that story uh it's a
phenomenal story
scott welcome to the into the impossible
podcast i remark to you
that you are not the first astronaut not
the second not that they're not
well you are the fourth astronaut but
you have a first you've gone boldly
where no man has gone before
because you're my first male astronaut
to ever come on the end of the
impossible puck
i think that's really exciting you know
it's so uh
emblematic of the fact that you know
there are more and more women
as part of the program doing out on the
cutting edge of of space exploration and
that's only going to uh increase as as
the years go along so
i'm i'm glad to be the the first male on
your show yeah
astronaut i should say yeah it's uh
it's it's a real treat and uh i think
the stories that you tell
really are so gripping i mean i couldn't
i couldn't you know turn off the i
listen to the book as i do
most of the time i actually have
accelerated learning by
uh just doing a 2x speed on most of my
audio books but
uh how to slow it down because there's
first of all
you speak relatively quickly at certain
points and you narrate the audio book
which is a
which is a great accomplishment but uh
but some of it is just like so gripping
the personal aspect of this book is
where i want to turn to because it's not
only a story of adventure
of exploration of the indomitable human
spirit
it's a love story it's a story of very
tenderness that appeals to me as a
father
as a husband and i want to talk first of
all just get very deep
very quickly and ask you the first time
you said goodbye
to your wife and and your son you know
after
already having been in space right but
saying goodbye to luke uh
named after luke skywalker not only the
the new testament luke but
the luca that all of us nerds worship uh
but that
that moment what was that like as a
father as a man forgetting about this
indomitable spirit that you have what
was that like as just as a human being
it is uh just a gut-wrenching um
uh time
in your life you know you you've worked
so hard to get to a point to
basically live out your childhood dream
of of going into space
and yet you realize that the the risks
that you're about to take are
really significant and and they're
things that you can't control
and and so i think one of the one of the
uh the things that happens is just
there's this uh
um compartmentalization that that you
have to
you have to vote otherwise you wouldn't
be able to
to say goodbye to your your kids uh it's
just
you you rationalize that the work that
you're about to do
uh has benefit to society to humanity to
the world
and sometimes you know risks are meant
to be taken to
to the betterment of society and so
that's that's how you
you have to you know approach it but if
you were to just think about it in terms
of well i'm going out
uh to go take a a fun ride
and i may not come back i'm not sure i
would have been able to to do that
without a sense of purpose
yeah you talk in the book it's it's so
heart-wrenching you talk about of course
space flight
you know we we lost something like two
percent and three percent of the
astronauts who traveled on the shuttle
and um i say to you know i'm a private
pilot nowhere near
uh any of the colleagues that that and
the experiences that you've had and high
performance you know fighter jets and
obviously on the space shuttle and
beyond but you know from
the perspective of aviation like no one
would get on an aircraft
you know commercial aircraft you knew
you had a two percent chance of dying
and and you talk about like writing
these like basically a card
to your children and and your wife you
know if you don't make it back
and and how this what is that ceremony
like what does that
feel like to do that well you really
really are
getting right to sorry to the chorus
we'll get to the constipation
story later to deal with these kinds of
emotions in a long time but
but yeah you you you write a note to
uh uh your your children um
that you you want them to know that you
know they were um
how much they meant to you and um and
you know how excited you are for their
future and you know
you end up writing these these things uh
with tears in your eyes
um hoping that it never ever gets given
to your kids so
we have uh another a fellow astronaut
um who is kind of there to support our
families while we're on our mission and
we
give these cards to this person who
hopes that he never
has to deliver them unfortunately you
know
i was a in a similar role in the
aftermath of the sts-107 columbia
tragedy i was
one of the designees and uh it's just a
horrific uh you know loss yeah
when i think about all the stories that
you tell and you know just trying to
rank
all the things that you've done in your
life you're a medical doctor
you're a mountain climber you're an
explorer you're an astronaut you're an
entrepreneur we're going to talk about
your business
uh i usually ask you know because i am
such a nerd but i usually ask my
audience
you know i asked my guest rather if an
alien comes you know from and i know you
can't talk about the alien autopsy
i promise you that's off limit oh uh oh
he's flashing it off he's flashing up
the alien gang sign
uh but if if somebody comes wakes you up
at three in the morning in a fever dream
and says scott who are you what
who how do you reflexively answer that
question you've done so much in your
life you're doing so much in your life
this this amazing you know project that
you're involved with now that
we're going to get into but tell me who
are you
oh yeah first off brian thank you very
much you you're very kind uh
no i i i guess um i'm an explorer at
heart
and uh my my main passion is to
uh um you know try and leave the the
planet a little bit better often
than when i arrived into it um yeah i've
been very fortunate
um and i think you can look at yourself
in the mirror and say you know you've
been
incredibly fortunate as well those of us
who have been
you know gifted uh you know um
wonderful families and friends and
education and opportunity
it's our our uh obligation to uh
to try and uh you know help those around
us and so
um i i've been around long enough i'm
i'm pretty old uh
cresting you know this upcoming summer
60 years old so
i've learned through that pathway
through life what my strengths and also
my weaknesses are
one of my strengths i think is a
creativity and
my inventiveness and so you know i'm i'm
using that to the best of my ability to
you know create
hopefully technologies that help people
um so it's
what i enjoy but it's also my way of of
you know giving back so that's my
purpose in life
i've been very fortunate um you know my
parents were very adventurous
growing up so i lived all over the world
that lived in west africa the middle
east and
graduated from high school in athens
greece so i had a travel bug an
adventurous spirit
and um and and so that kind of led me
into exploration
into climbing and to other things diving
and uh
had this opportunity to become an
astronaut
and uh what i found through my journeys
is that
when we go to challenging places like
you going to antarctica
uh you know when explorers go uh deep
beneath the oceans or up into space
you know it challenges the uh the
innovators to
gather science there uh to support human
life there
uh to to go you know work and do more in
those environments and when you
when you you're able to do that you can
bring back value to
all of us back here on earth and uh so
that's kind of
in a nutshell uh what gets me fired up
and
how i got here i guess that's lovely
yeah so just a quick uh
interlude because this is a part you're
all part of an experiment not the kind
that you know scott used to do on
on living subjects but you are a part of
an experiment on clubhouse on youtube
on facebook on twitch even i think i'm
on twitch thanks to
thanks to jake kuhn who's my uh jack
jake of all trades it does so much for
the podcast i want to say hi to
everybody on clubhouse scott is on
clubhouse
which convinced me to get over the
hurdle i want to say hi to you folks
over there this is the into the
impossible podcast where we talk about
uh very very difficult challenging
things that expand the human spirit
we do that with high achievers
performers ranging from billionaires to
nobel prize winners
and uh we want to involve you in these
conversations and i look to people like
the joe rogans of the world who i love
very much and i'm a religious listener
thereof
but the one thing i'm claiming i can do
that joe's not doing
is involve you guys in these
conversations so please think of
questions you want to ask to scott
how often do you get to talk to a real
life space walker veteran of
seven spacewalks i believe five shuttle
missions um
international cooperation with the
russian uh government actually that
brings up one thing
uh that uh that i wanted to lead off
with which was what i asked jessica
coming here so
you and i are talking you're in houston
right now scott
actually i'm in phoenix you're in
phoenix oh okay a little bit closer so i
talked to jessica back
in um in january about a year ago
exactly
uh just last month and she was on the
iss and she had just completed the all
first all-female spacewalk it was really
and i was like she's actually closer to
me you know in space
over her alma mater than she is uh when
she's in houston or whatever so
um so so you're you're currently you're
you're in phoenix
but um but yeah thinking about the
distances and the notion of nasa
as a brand i have t-shirts my kids have
t-shirts
nasa is like the most powerful brand in
the universe maybe giving this guy a run
uh for his money this is my spacex mug
for those of you on youtube i'm dr brian
keating on youtube
um so i've got a spacex mug but i think
the nasa brand is even stronger what do
you think about nasa
you know kind of ink what are your
perceptions of that as an insider
it's it's seen the world over um you
know i
i've done a lot of high altitude
climbing including uh
up on everest and in the kambu region of
nepal
in remote parts of africa and southeast
asia
you see the the nasa meatball it's it's
ubiquitous and it's
um i think it harkens back to the the
the triumphs of the apollo era you know
when the planet came together as a whole
it wasn't united states and nasa who
who set foot on the moon but it was
humanity that that had done it
and uh there's a a global ownership of
of that and imagining that you know we
could actually uh
you know surmount a challenge like that
so i think it's the most
as you say the most powerful brand on
earth uh
and outer space as well but spacex is
a phenomenal brand as well i'm really
bullish about
what they're doing and the uh the vision
to colonize mars and
and do other extraordinary things uh um
it's an exciting time to be alive right
it really is you look at the
you know what happened with the apollo
program as you just mentioned
and i should say is it's really tough
we'll get into everest hopefully in a
little bit
but you know scott is i think you're the
first maybe the only astronaut to ever
climb the summit of mount everest he's
the second person now
second person now okay but you were the
first person there to do it and you
brought with you a moon rock which i
think is just so accepting you know it's
like
maybe defeats the purpose it's like they
have some interesting rocks up there too
uh but i thought it was so cool and you
did it in a way as a tribute to
to to your comrades to the people that
got you there and the thing i like most
about you
is i i kind of feel like uh it reminds
me a little bit about neil
of neil armstrong speaking of the moon
speaking of apollo
uh 11 uh for a second um do you know
what uh neil armstrong what was his
profession what is the
only profession that can top being the
first
human being to walk on the moon do you
know what he did after he
came home from uh to back to earth
uh well i mean he he always considered
himself
first and foremost a pilot uh a test
pilot that was his
in his blood and yeah oh by the way i
got a chance to fly to the moon
very very very humble about it yeah of
course but
no i'm not sure what he would have said
to that question well he uh i
i don't know either you certainly have a
much closer contact him
but he did become a college professor so
when i when i'm down in my profession oh
they're you know this three hour a week
job is so hard you know what am i gonna
do
but um but i think back that this is the
profession chosen by the first human
being to ever go the earth
and it made me think of something that i
associated very deeply after
you know i haven't known you very long
but i know you i feel like i know you
one of the most important things about
you that i want to take away from this
book
besides your spirit besides these
wonderful quotes in the book is
that you are incredibly coachable what i
see you as as
you know back then now you're 60 but you
still seem like you have that beginner's
mind that student's mind
and i always point out you know some of
my listeners in clubhouse or
of russian extraction and they'll
correct me if i'm wrong i'm sure but the
word scientist
in the russian language you probably
know this better than i do having
studied russian
the word scientist means one who was
taught and to me
that means that a scientist or someone
with a scientific curiosity
should be a teacher but should also be a
student and what do you say about that
were you just born with that kind of
coach ability like some of my kids have
it some of them don't
can you train someone to be coachable
trainable so that they can become a
leader like you
uh interesting uh interesting concept
and and thank you for the
those kind words i i would con consider
myself insatiably
curious you know i've uh um and i'm
self-taught in many different areas i'm
i'm
probably not an expert in very many
things but uh you know i i like to
challenge myself in different areas and
and so i like to as an inventor
i'll digress here for a moment i like to
figure out
um not just the areas that in our
society that are broken but
i like to think through you know how can
we fix those things and i i
consider that the best inventors
essentially motivated whiners people who
not only identify problems but then have
the wherewithal the curiosity the
the the gumption to uh to come up with
solutions and so that's
that's how i i see myself but yeah i
think uh
um i i think it is possible to train
people to be
more curious if you if you show them the
uh how exciting it is to
you know to understand how something
works and and to question you know is
this the best way
we can do this and uh yeah so i'm a
physician by training
and um you know i talk about this all
the time when i give keynotes but
you know if if we didn't have a
perpetual sense of curiosity
we'd still be doing bloodletting for
everything that ailed us right it
would just be we'd be nowhere um and
think about you know
our understanding of of the heavens and
and astrophysics if we didn't
you know continue to challenge ourselves
fantastic so i have my first
ever question and it's fitting that it
comes from a good friend of mine
uh philip greenspun who is actually
responsible for me getting
invited to clubhouse it's a it's a
select club like you know going to the
moon
and and being a nasa astronaut i'm sure
but uh phil is up on stage in clubhouse
and he's gonna ask a question he's not
only
a uh an incredible friend but he was
actually one of the people who got me
the deepest i've become into aviation
and was kind of a mentor
to me as a pilot and still is and he's
actually
an upcoming guest we recorded an episode
of the end of the impossible podcast
with philip greenspun
uh about a month or two ago anyway phil
dr phil greenspun
how are you doing i call phil the most
interesting man that you've never heard
of
phil do you have a question for the good
doctor astronaut scott
varazynski
normally i hate to discuss books
that i've actually read you know it's
much better to talk about books that
i haven't read but i have read scott's
book and in fact i read it to
uh one of the kids as bedtime reading uh
so thank you for that scott oh that's
wonderful things that
really struck me from your book was
you said that you know humans are
suffering a lot of back damage when they
spend time in zero gravity
right and i'm wondering if you can talk
about about that
and whether you know that's ultimately
going to be what
uh limits human ability to hang out in
space
and do all the stuff that elon musk and
other people have
done for humans in space is it our backs
that will let us down
yeah it's terrible to have when your
back throws out on you but uh
it's a great question uh uh dr phillip
and i appreciate
uh your kind words about uh my book as
well so
uh there are a lot of threats actually
uh for
yeah prolonged habitation in space and
i'll just run through them
quickly but radiation um
you know when you're outside of the
earth's magnetic field you're much more
susceptible to galactic cosmic radiation
and
kernel mass ejections and all this
radiation flux from around the
uh not only our sun but from around
our our solar system so that's one
big threat higher risk of of cancers and
and other
sequelae from radiation to the extent
that you know when we go to mars when
elon you know gets us to mars they're
gonna have to actually
uh bury the habitats underneath uh the
regolith
to shield the crew from from those
deleterious effects so
that's a big big problem another issue
is eyesight
our long-duration astronauts are
experiencing significant shifts in their
visual acuity likely as a result of
increased intracranial pressure
it's it's pressing on the back side of
their eyeball
flattening it and they're coming back
with uh what appears
uh to be potentially uh permanent
uh changes in their in their vision so
if if we're to live
indefinitely in space you know would
would this effect stop
or or you know would it cause astronauts
uh to
to go blind over time it's hard to say
um
and then the the third uh element that
you raised is uh
is disc disease and and uh as you're
probably aware
the the spine is made up of these
vertebral bodies and it
in between them they're sort of like a
jelly donut uh there's a
uh inside the the jelly donut it's
called the nucleus pulposus not to get
too nerdy about it but it's it's a piece
of uh
kind of gelatinous material that with a
lot of stress
can shoot out tear the this
tissue around it called the annulus and
press on your nerve roots
and that's what happened to me actually
i i ended up
throwing out a disc on a mountaineering
expedition
to mount everest actually i was at 24
000 feet above sea level
and i threw a disc which is really a bad
spot to get injured but
i persevered i had to turn around of
course
and came back to houston and had
corrective surgery
the reason it's happening is without the
gravity vector
pressing down on our our spines up in
microgravity
um your spine straightens and it's also
likely that those
jelly donuts uh kind of swell without
you know the continual gravitational
force
on the uh the skeleton and uh it's
tearing
the the the donut if you will
and allowing uh the disc to uh to
to fly out so a lot of astronauts have
had
both uh cervical spine neck uh spine
issues as well as uh lumbar
disc disease which is what affected me
so it yeah it's a real
threat for for long duration astronauts
and it's uh
it's very oh so scott the on on
clubhouse if you wouldn't mind
uh you can go up on the stage and then
uh just mute your microphone so we don't
get feedback
but um but then people are um
if you just mute the phone volume good
okay yes all right great
i follow instructions well perfect yeah
you are coachable that is great
there we go okay so jake let me know if
that worked uh
i want to say that yeah when you were on
the the scenes of you and
and mount everest are really thrilling
you talk about your
your back you talk about um you know
this pain and then the one just
hilarious line you're talking about
you know you had to come down in your
first attempt and you're lying on this
glacier and you're like well at least it
was the world's biggest ice pack
and i just feel like you have this you
have this good cheer and i
and i think you know not to like really
uh i'm not gonna make the comparison i'm
gonna stop the the mutual admiration
society soon trust me
but um but they say you know people that
survive horrific
things in life whether it be awful
prison sentences that they didn't
deserve let's just say things like that
that you know the ones that survived
were not the ones that were just like
uh just relentless optimists like like
uh admiral stockdale
famous example john mccain they weren't
optimistic
but they went with things in other words
they would look at a situation again i'm
not comparing what you went through
you know obviously you wouldn't say it
but but i wouldn't say it either
but nevertheless to have that kind of
attitude of looking towards
well almost like stoic but but in a
good-natured way
again is that something you're born with
is that something you can coach somebody
to be
uh you know to adapt in those ways and
if so you know
what what age do you have to start you
know when my kids turn teenagers is it
too late
well teens are in kind of their own
little category off to the side and then
they they re-enter society
a little bit later so don't don't worry
about the aliens have returned their
brains to their bodies right
no i resilience is something that
certainly can be trained
and i think um uh what was it going to
say along those lines i i think
team experiences are things that kind of
entrain that
kind of perspective when you've you
overcome
challenges uh with the team and you
realize that
your impact on the rest of the team is
very significant if you have a dower
face if you have a negative
uh perspective on it you're going to
drag the whole team down whereas if if
the glass is three-quarters of the way
full hey we're going to get through this
we just need to
brainstorm a little bit more we're going
to keep going
um that i think carries the day and so
that you know i've been a part of a lot
of
team pursuits you know athletics and and
otherwise and i
i think that's probably where i picked
it up but
yeah uh so talking about that in teams
you know part of being
you know coachable at some level is also
being you know
being a good leader i think is is it
kind of goes in hand in hand so you
can't be a good leader if you're not a
good follower i don't want to you know
say it in a negative sense
but you talk about some setbacks that
you had after uh mount everest
and we'll get back to that in just a bit
but talk about the setbacks that you
faced
and the position of leadership that you
were put in in the knolls program and
and other things that you uh that you
engaged with that really kind of
crystallized your character to make you
even more suitable in my opinion but i
think you're more humble than
than i would be on your behalf if i were
you i'd be a whole lot less humble
uh but that's uh that's just me so yeah
how do you take those in stride those
because these are the highest
performance type a individuals in the
world you know
uh besides some of my colleagues in the
in the university but how did you handle
that criticism and how did you use it as
fuel to improve yeah well
there is a a section in my book where i
i really got
uh a serious smackdown and i deserved it
um quite honestly and it's hard when
you're around
other really high achieving folks you
want to be
on your best at all at all times and
it hurts doubly so when when you feel
like you've let your
your teammates down and so this is an
expedition
part of the national outdoor leadership
school or knowles where
our shuttle crews would get together
before a flight
and uh you know gone to the wilderness
for about 10 days
exchange leadership duties day to day
and
and learn about each other each other's
strengths and weaknesses leadership
styles followership
skills those kinds of things and i
probably had the most
experience on expeditions at the most
navigation you know kind of wilderness
navigation skills
and i was in a hurry i was hungry uh one
of my one of my many weaknesses is that
when i get hangry
you know better feed me quick or you
know i get very
i i never uh verbally get uh
unpleasant but i just don't want to talk
you know and so
i was in a hurry to get where we wanted
to go and
uh in any event i made some
leadership mistakes uh poor
communication
and i got uh really dressed down
by my space shuttle commander in front
of
people uh whom i was going to be
co-leading for the next year and a half
and it was really
uh the most humbling uh you know
experience
perhaps in my life certainly in the top
ten
and uh and so you grow from that um
and uh and so it certainly shaped
um my leadership skills uh every day
since that point
um and what i uh
one of the many kind of uh leadership
lessons that i've learned is
every person whether they're the the
youngest
uh noob in on the team or the most
senior
person on your your squatter unit or
whatever
it may have the situational awareness
that will save the day and so
you really need to to drought the very
best of you know your multidisciplinary
teams
and uh so i've been much more yeah
an active listener or trying to be uh
as a leader than i ever have before yeah
i
interviewed a very famous uh navy
commander
by the name of david marquez who wrote a
book called turn the ship around
it's become a classic in leadership and
the second book is called
you know this guy commanded a 1.4
billion dollar nuclear submarine
and his newest book is called leadership
is language
and it's all about like these these
mental traps and hacks that high
performance individuals like him
and you i'm not going to include myself
in there but we use these hacks and it's
really
kind of a shortcut it's sometimes it's
beneficial to us we'll say like
everybody good to go right and he and he
actually uses the example of the
of the columbia loss where you know they
went around the room and everyone's like
all right you know we're good to go
right and when you ask that question
there's an implicit bias of authority
that i have to agree and it's become you
know kind of rooted out
of the nasa culture a lot more but it
was certainly pervasive and in those
really high stakes
you know uh situations i think it's
that's where i want to learn
leadership lessons from and hopefully if
you can handle that in a situation like
you know trying to summit you know
everest or being in space when a
micro meteorite you know comes whizzing
by uh then you could probably handle it
in the board room when you're trying to
roll out you know version 3.7 of an app
so we have another question uh from one
of our clubhouse listeners and i want to
remind people we're on clubhouse but
we're also on youtube as usual i'm not
giving up youtube i love my youtube
audience
worked hard to build them and we have a
guest by the name
of bf peterson so i'm going to call bf
to the stage
and if you're if he's there we can take
it if not we can come back
we have other people there my friend
miguel is out there in clubhouse
if he wants to take a take a stab and
get uh
and and step up to the stage again this
is a new experiment for me but
as uh dr scott opens his book he says
everything is possible until proven
impossible and i think that's really
fitting especially the name of this
podcast is into the impossible which is
a line
from arthur c clarke uh along with his
many contributions including 2001 a
space odyssey
uh which i'm sure you've seen or maybe
maybe you avoid it do you watch movies
where people you know
come to grips
i love sci-fi including even the really
bad
uh renditions of space like armageddon
and uh
you know things of that nature i watch
them all oh that's great
okay so while all waiting for another
question to come up um
i want to talk about something that you
uh you mentioned in the book
uh you talk about uh you know this this
this notion of of kind of adversarial
leadership in the sense that like
you all go around the room and say like
what did he do what did scott do wrong
what
you know like you kind of use the red
team approach from the military where
there's
adversarial but it's meant obviously in
good nature
yeah so um so uh going through that
and then you know after going through
that i was actually um interviewed by
a nobel prize winner yesterday for my
own podcast don't ask questions about
that
it's kind of weird but i wrote a book
about the nobel prize and
uh and specifically the flaws in the
nobel prize and he's one of the
characters in the book and
he read the book unlike my wife but but
anyway i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna hold her to that i just
dedicated it to her you know no big deal
uh sarah if you're out there but um but
in reality
you know he said well what's wrong with
because i make the point that the nobel
prize can only be won by three people
at most and that was never really the
design of alfred nobel so when he was
i was hanging out with him he left his
nobel prize so he's not going to get
that back that
that's mine forever but he uh he said
like
his complaint against my book is that i
kind of
you know downplayed competition or i
talked about the negative aspects of
competition and one of the examples i
use
you actually mention it in the book it's
the plaque that was carried by the
apollo 11 astronauts
to land on the moon's surface still
there we hope
uh and and that says we came in peace
for the benefit of all mankind
signed by one richard m nixon and
i point out that the nobel prize has a
thing on its back or
it's golden plaque that barry this nobel
laureate who interviewed me
uh he agrees with in other words it says
um the nobel prize should be given out
to those who cause the greatest benefit
to mankind
and i said barry if if indeed the apollo
missions were about benefiting mankind
instead of about competition why have we
not been back why have we not been back
in over 50 this would be the 53rd year
right uh 52nd year
in july so what is it about competition
does it have a place in the culture of
of excellence like nasa
where you know might even be within the
astronaut core themselves there's only
it's a zero-sum game you know if you go
on the shuttle that's one
you know fewer slot for me so i guess
the long-winded way of asking
is competition a good thing or can it be
toxic
competition certainly can be toxic but i
think it needs to be used
uh with the right uh amplification
uh it it can't get to the level of
toxicity
um and i think nasa has always done a
very good job of that you know
if you're uh i'll just talk about the
context of
you know crew selection for example um
it it wasn't the same people flying over
and over again there was there was a
rotation and
hey we need a spacewalker on this flight
we need a robotics person we need a
commander and a pilot and so there was a
an orderly fashion in which you would
rotate back up and
get a chance to fly again but but i i do
think that you know competition is what
fuels our
our uh our economy and and i think our
innovation if you look at
i think the wonderful competition that's
happening in a commercial human space
flight right now between spacex blue
origin
uh you know there are other
vendors of course boeing and lockheed
uh there's axiom space and uh these
other
um uh space
um uh companies that will be taking
people
um to the edge of space and and beyond
and i think that's really good
it forces uh companies to to be more
competitive to drive the prices down to
make it
available for all of us you know elon
musk has probably already
reduced the the cost uh to orbit by a
factor of 10.
if we can get it a hundred or a thousand
times uh
you know less expensive than the space
shuttle then all of us will become
astronauts you'll fly from san diego to
uh heathrow in 45 minutes
in a you know kind of a sub-orbital
ballistic
you know kind of craft my luggage will
get there three days later
yeah well but
but i'll take it i'll i'll take it you
can buy new clothes when you get there
i've had to do that a lot even on a
non-stop flight from san diego to
oakland so
you know i don't know how you lose the
luggage on a non-stop flight that's 48
minutes long but anyway
nothing against southwest airlines i'm
not bitter at all
those those were not designer underwear
despite whoever stole them
they're in for a rude awakening okay so
we do have a question uh bf is back
uh let's see bf are you there and
are you prepared to chat with a live
nasa
astronaut okay let me tune you up hold
on one second go for it vf
hi uh uh thanks for taking my question
um and thank you brian for
this forum i just kind of wanted to know
you touched on it briefly in terms of
teams
the interaction between civilian
component i guess you could call it the
whole thing is a civilian component but
nasa has this deep
military history as well and relevance
sorry i'm at the gym a little out of
breath how do you see
those these people are going to be
embarking
on the greatest journey in the history
of the world
interacting with each other i know you
touched on it briefly
briefly you had interactions when you
got hangry
um but how do you see them working
together the scientists the engineers
the roboticists
the pilots the doctors and also
with that is there any role that you
think
would be good to add poet artists
do they bring any value to a situation
like that
thank you very much thank you thank you
so much
that's a wonderful question and and uh
first off i would say
you know for these expedition class type
missions you know i think you're talking
about you know
lunar outpost mars outpost those kinds
of
long duration missions that are ahead of
us as part of project
artemis and things like that what
what happens is a coalescence of you
know there's a
a sense of mission that's shared between
every crew member from the commander on
down to the
most junior person and uh by and large
uh there's just a a great
camaraderie and a sense of purpose and
um self-startedness uh part of it i
think is
owing to the selection process you know
they they select people who have done
well on
on teams in the past whether it's in my
background i
i worked in emergency medicine so
you know working in in medicine you've
got to
be part of a high functioning team or a
really bad things are going to happen
so that was kind of and i've been a part
of other expeditions so
i had that kind of skill set uh military
operators
bring you know that kind of culture as
well and it it all comes together when
you start training together and working
together so it's a very natural
sort of a thing but i am really excited
about the future
uh first i i think you know thinking
about suborbital space flight you know
it's richard branson and
and um virgin galactic
and blue origin very soon we'll be
flying you know artists and
and poets and and writers and
photographers uh
creative thinkers even just up into the
you know uh suborbital realm it's it's
going to be a life-changing
uh you know kind of epiphany for for
those creatives
and um and certainly as we start to
establish
communities on the moon and on mars we
need
the full diversity the full strength of
our our society to be present
and um and so my my only uh
you know kind of uh immersion into
kind of a uh
second culture and i think brian you can
probably speak to this more than i
i could you've i think you've wintered
over at south pole station no
no i'm not i'm not that insane but some
of my best friends have
yeah well you know that culture you're
well but
um you know there are about 44 souls who
spend the entire winter
off the grid i mean they have very
limited internet connectivity
there's no way in or out for seven to
nine months and they become their own
little society
and so having some diversity in that
culture
is really important so they do have
artists and and uh
and other types of creatives and i i
think it's going to be essential
as humanity goes beyond
you know when we wanted to get uh
somebody to win her over for the bicep2
experiment we put out a job ad and we
said you know you make 80 000
for the winter and all you have to do is
work one night and we got a lot of
people you know
surprising uh we have another question
uh from a listener on clubhouse and
again we're monitoring all uh youtube
again this is the into the impossible
podcast i'm your fearful host during
these pandemic podcasts
the name of brian keating and we have dr
scott farazynski
who has been to space uh more times than
i have children or you know about as
many times
and uh spacewalk certainly more than
that and uh we have a we have a
guest uh on the stage in clubhouse by
the name of uh
mustac or mustac i hope i'm pronouncing
your name right tell us
how do you pronounce your name a stack
uh it's correct
so just my thoughts scott um
in terms of um the voyage that we're
thinking of in terms of mars
um what what do you feel are the
technical
and physical obstacles that are there
to be able to complete such such a
technological
is this my very good friend mustac patel
from from the uk
by any chance that i met at davos
there's a planted question no further
questions
well great to hear your voice my friend
uh well it's a great question
thank you ms doug all right
there are many things actually that we
need to uh to develop we're
we we can certainly visit um
mars even with the technology that we
have today but i think
in order to really successfully exploit
live colonize
on mars for a long period of time we
need to continue to develop
really essential technologies one of the
things i already spoke to which is
radiation protection and one of the
concepts is to actually build habitats
in lava tubes um underneath the uh
the crust of uh of the planet to to
protect uh from the you know cancer and
other kind of sequelae from the
radiation environment
it's a high dust environment so
developing robust technologies that can
allow people to get in and out of that
external environment
safely without you know inhaling lots of
dust and
maybe causing the equivalent of
asbestosis and lung cancers
growing plants and and living off of the
land
is going to be very important can we
extract
water from maybe the slopes of
olympus mons the tallest mountain in the
the known
solar system uh 25 miles tall five five
times taller than mount everest can we
can we extract water to to grow plants
to drink
water to to generate oxygen
can we develop technologies that will
allow us to get to mars a lot quicker
than
stupid chemical rockets that we're using
now so um this is probably more in your
your your line of work brian but you
know plasma physics uh
has has allowed us to develop plasma ion
engines that would allow us to
continually continuously accelerate
to mars getting there in perhaps 70 days
as opposed to seven to nine months
so minimizing the exposure that we have
on that transit uh to get to the red
planet
and um and and thus limiting our our
exposure to uh
radiation as well so the lots of lots of
cool uh problems for technologists to
work on
and what i see when i look at your
career and your book the stuff that
you're doing now
which we'll turn to uh is kind of this
this principle that one of my friends uh
good friend james altucher
is a kind of an influencer to me a very
famous podcaster and just a brilliant
guy he talks about it we'll call it um
idea dating
he actually calls it idea sex but
basically let's say you have n
ideas uh you know then you can form
actually n squared over two
you know roughly n squared over two
pairs of ideas so that's kind of the
network effect that facebook and other
things are based on
that things grow ex you know
geometrically they grow as the power
uh of the of the size of the network so
i see you as somebody who's into
mountain climbing has done skiing
has done scuba diving has done obviously
aviation and space uh medicine
and and now you you kind of turn to this
new direction with fluidity technology
for liberty.tech to get a new
way of getting into the you know
pilotless vehicle so in terms of drones
do you attribute that to like you know
kind of fortune favors the prepared mind
in that you have so many different
interests you're
you're so poly mathematical uh or is it
that
better to go deep into one thing like
when i'm when i'm an emergency physician
i'm that's all i'm going to think about
when i'm an astronaut that's all i'm
going to think about
or is it better to be broad and have
this network effect of what my friend
calls idea sex so
what what is more kind of uh promotional
of
you know being creative being successful
uh being you know not being a dilettante
like i'm often
accused of but you know how how do you
how do you balance breadth
versus depth well i i that's a great
question and
and i i can't say that there's a
one-size-fits-all answer i just know
that i
i'm uh more along the lines of idea sex
and you know
adhd um i'm i'm a
generalist i i enjoy learning
uh as much as i can about every
environment that i get exposed to and
one of the reasons i
i love being an astronaut is i was
exposed
to not just i wasn't just a physician
astronaut i
had to know quite a bit about
oceanography uh meteorology
planetary geology combustion physics
astrophysics
uh plant biology so i dabbled in all
these different areas it was fascinating
i was
i was the surrogate principal
investigator on
on the space shuttle or space station um
and so
for me that was just incredible candy
and it
i absorbed a lot of it not all of it and
i'm not deep
in many areas besides probably
medical technologies perhaps in
aerospace but
i know a fair amount of a bunch of
different areas and
and that's in my toolkit so that when i
see a problem
as a product developer i can call back
upon that
bit of knowledge and uh i know just
enough to be dangerous
so my my happy space is being
a generalist uh but there's certainly
super high achievers who are you know
laser focused in one area
and uh and that's their key to success
as well
yeah very good okay so next up
we have a very good friend of mine who
makes the
some of the intro and outro music for
the into the impossible podcast
it's none of the miguel tully i'm gonna
uh play some of his
music and see if we can hear it in the
background i'm not sure
one of his dedicated tracks yeah here it
comes up
this is uh one of miguel's wonderful
tracks that he made for me
and he's working on some space art we're
actually working i
did a podcast with nicole stott oh great
we flew twice on the shuttle
and she's an inspiration to me and she's
a wonderful artist and i started to
think
you know some of the astronauts came
back from the lunar surface and they
brought back on their spacesuit uh
some lunar dust and i guess they got to
keep it and one of them it might have
been edgar mitchell i forgot who it was
but he took the the dirt you know on the
spacesuit and ground it up and put into
his paintings
ellen bean it's alan bean right okay
girl 12. yep
and so um but it turns out that it's a
felony
for someone like me to have a lunar rock
you actually had possession of a lunar
rock collected by
uh by neil armstrong i think uh and you
had it for a year
uh it was a little longer than they
intended right on loan only alone right
yeah
but it turns out you can actually buy uh
you can buy
actual fragments of the moon that were
delivered not by nasa astronauts but by
the united states postal service
you know you can get them on ebay
basically but they're meteorites so they
landed on the surface of
uh of uh antarctica in some cases as
your as your wife right that's uh that's
right that's what she got her start in
was she at case western or she had
arizona she's arizona state she's at
arizona state the school of earth and
space exploration
very good yeah i've got very good
friends there at asu it's a phenomenal
school
anyway miguel and i are working on a
project where we're hoping to mix in i
sent him some meteorites from campo de
cielo
in argentina and some uh and some lunar
material
uh from the uh lunar surface that i got
also on ebay not from the apollo again
this is from a meteorite that fell in
northwest
africa in 2011. anyway miguel it's a
long introduction
uh i want to say hi to you and wish you
blessings my friend miguel
is an army vet and uh and he's uh he's a
patriot and he is an incredible
supporter of the show
miguel you are live with dr scott hey
miguel
hey dr keating good to see you on here
it's great to be here
yeah i had a question for scott uh just
wondering what is the most
cherished piece of memorabilia that
you've acquired in your career
either from space or just from your
career
oh gosh that's that's a cool question i
you know um
like uh probably uh you and many other
folks here we
i've uh given talks you know for years
and years
uh and it's rare that you get asked a
question that you've never ever been
asked before and that's one of them
miguel so i
i applaud you for that um so i i i'll
give you
perhaps an answer that will surprise you
but it's probably the
the most worthless piece of uh material
uh by by weight or volume or however
you'd want to quantify it
but it's uh it has incredible
significance to me
um on my last trip up into space i had
to
working with a wonderful team of folks
repair a live solar panel
and it was a pretty hairy thing to go
out and do to work on a
fully electrified solar panel out at the
tip of the space station
using procedures and tools that had
never been conjured up before using a
robotic arm that had never been
coupled together in this way before and
i was out there
at the very tip of the space station you
know sewing this thing back together
when i came back from that trip uh it
we're all elated that
this repair had come together it worked
so flawlessly
it was really a triumph for the nasa
team
um one of the engineers who had worked
you know through the night it was like a
is an apollo 13 sort of a an event where
people were working around the clock
you know on mock-ups hey how can we
repair the solar panel and
this guy they were obviously eating lots
of domino's pizza and drinking a lot of
coffee
he cut two little oval pieces of
cardboard punctured a hole in both of
those little tabs
tied a string between it put a little
piece of tape on it
and um it was the very first prototype
of the repair
uh that we would be going out and doing
three days hence
um and we called this thing a cuff link
it was essentially a piece of wire about
five feet in length with two pieces of
aluminum shim stock that had been
you know carefully cut to fit through
the solar panel uh to allow us to
stitch the the solar panel back together
but uh
my my prized possession is a domino's
pizza box here we go
wow
it's uh not quite apollo 13 but but
still they uh improvise and
as i always say except when i take a
test failure is not an option
thank you so much jonathan knowles is in
the audience oh jonathan hello yeah
jonathan
welcome to the stage let me add you uh
to the stage
and uh i will take your question